joe concha fox news contributor joe
let's get to your favorite daily
activity watching cnn
roll it
people those who are outraged weren't
going to vote for stacey abrams anyway
if my kid was in the classroom would i
be outraged the answer is definitely not
i don't want to see an adult in an
elementary school without a mask on um
at the same time republicans rushing in
to pile on stacey abrams is a little
ridiculous because republicans in the
state have pushed against mass mandates
now joe to review abrams was the one who
got caught with her mask down how did
this become republicans fault
it's interesting right uh todd the issue
was in stacey abrams blatant hypocrisy
as we could see in that photo there it's
anyone who points out said hypocrisy in
this case republicans and it's amazing
you know republicans are always seizing
you ever notice that if they're not
seizing on a situation they are pouncing
on a situation uh but when democrats do
it they're defenders of democracy or
something uh but but anyway why didn't
the washington post by the way in their
feature
on adams in this situations abrams
excuse me uh not show her masculist in
its story you know there are many to
choose from now uh as we're seeing uh
from clay clay travis uh but the paper
largely serves at the pleasure of the
democratic party uh that that's
certainly for sure in this case somehow
uh they craptastically paint stacey
abrams as the victim of evil republican
seizing here for no good reason uh it's
also worth noting by the way the
washington post and its history of
endorsing presidential candidates has
never once endorsed a republican go
figure it's like cnn in print right it's
mostly a partisan opinion-based
organization under the guise of news so
yeah whether it's cnn whether it's the
washington post they will defend stacy
abrams the same woman who has sowed
doubt in elections for decades to come
because she said her race in georgia her
last one was stolen from her uh that
that's your girl right there as far as
being a media darling like we've never
seen since michael avenatti quite
frankly
and then now this democratic governors
are ending mass mandates and now even
cnn's medical
analyst is supporting the democratic led
states dropping the school mass mandates
i'm going to roll this site and we're
going to talk about it on the other side
circumstances have changed case counts
are declining also the science has
changed the responsibility should shift
from a government mandate imposed from
the state or the local district of the
school rather it should shift to an
individual responsibility by the family
so it's obviously constant shifting you
can't keep track of what they say so
does this have something to do do you
think perhaps with the midterms
oh actually the science has not changed
whatsoever the political to your point
calculation has changed uh you know i
i've watched that medical analyst on cnn
for the past two years now and she has
been as pro
mask in schools pro mask in general as
anybody on television and for her to
suddenly say now well you know things
are changing on the ground no no schools
have been shown and this has been for
quite some time now to be the safest
places for almost anyone to be children
are safest from this virus among almost
any age group obviously unless you're
counting you know one and two-year-olds
so to this point it's just so blatantly
obvious what is going on here and i'm
just wondering
uh when is the uh jensaki snark tweet
coming for my governor here in new
jersey who was dropping a mass mandate
because she did it to glen yunken in
virginia i guess because her kids go
there but now that murphy does it i
guess everything's changed it's almost
like they're just waiting for these
these blue states to just make a
decision on what they're going to do and
they're going to follow suit i mean it's
just it's called leading that's
co-leading hey joe before we go you know
what that was that was a 180 on
360. i was really proud of that line i
wrote it right there wow yeah i'm pretty
impressed by that you can use that
throughout the show
please use that on the other shows
because you're on the network a lot joe
koncha thank you very much sir i'm you
get full uh attribution here believe me
i mean you thought of that in the shower
and you deserve credit so well done i
wrote it down on my paper i've been
holding onto it for six hours joe thanks